welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with russia taking
a hard line to control how its war on
ukraine is reported from russia a new
law threatens prison time for anyone
speaking out against the government and
for what it says is false information
about the invasion now a growing list of
media outlets including cbs news are
either being blocked voluntarily
suspending or limiting their news
coverage in russia roxanna siberia is in
our london bureau with the latest on
this roxanna good morning
good morning jeff cbs news along with
abc cnn and the bbc are some of the
network's suspending reporting in russia
in a statement cbs news says it's not
currently broadcasting from there given
the new media laws this morning the
kremlin is defending those laws saying
it's battling an information war
no to war was the final message
broadcast by tv rain one of russia's
last independent media outlets the staff
then walk out leaving behind a parting
shot the ballet swan lake a nod to what
soviet russia played in times of turmoil
a similar scene played out at russia's
oldest liberal radio station echo of
moscow which says it's been forced to
close we
just can say
welcome to the ussr these acts of
defiance come as russia's parliament
passed a law effectively criminalizing
the spread of information opposing the
kremlin's narrative on the war against
ukraine
simply calling it a war or an invasion
instead of a special military operation
can lead to up to 15 years behind bars
the kremlin is trying to control
discontent over the war at least 8 000
protesters have been arrested and
russians are reeling from crushing
western sanctions in moscow residents
rushed to a local ikea store just before
the furniture giant joined other western
brands pulling out of the country
the shopper says this is the first time
i've seen anything like this it feels
like we're lined up to buy salt or bread
in wartime
russia has also blocked facebook and
twitter inside the country parent
company meta says the move will silence
millions of russians and cut them off
from reliable information dana
a little surprised that putin would try
to control that narrative roxanna thank
you